and she a little bit more I make my
number four choice also based on a real
person the once again highly
romanticized it's Edward D Wood jr. from
the movie Ed Wood considered by made to
be one of the worst filmmakers of all
time you can't help but still love Ed
Wood for the mere reason that he loves
what he does yeah he's making stuff that
a lot of people don't consider good but
the fact that there's a story that
actually respects how much he enjoys
doing it is really quite touching and a
love letter to those that really respect
what they do and enjoy it so much
to me I feel like this character is a
reminder to why so many artists do what
they do there's always the risk that
what they're doing will not succeed for
some it may never succeed at least not
the way that they intend but this
character is a reminder that you got to
do it simply because you want to do it
help you need to do it and even if it
turns out nobody ever enjoys it that's
not the reason why you did to begin with
you did it because that passion is
burning and won't be settled until you
do something with it I think in a world
where so many people try to please other
people
there's a great admiration for people
that just do what they want to do
because that's what they want to do it's
not hurting anybody and they're not
forcing anybody to see it they're just
expressing themselves in whatever
strange untraditional way that they want
and if you don't like it you don't like
it but who are we to say they can't do
it yeah well enjoy making fun of it and
even get a good laugh analyzing just how
terrible the material is but the
constant passion enjoy this character
has for his work and how much he will
never give up just to get out there what
he wants to get out there is not only
inspiring it's addictive I can say
easily I get a lot of my passion from
this character every artist should know
going in that not everything they make
is going to be perfect they're going to
make mistakes they're going to make
things that not everybody is going to
like hell the majority might hate it but
if you're going in for the reason that
you want people to like your work you're
going in for the wrong reason and that's
what makes ed woods so special even
though he made such awful films he went
in because this was what he wanted to do
it was his life it was his love I've
seen plenty of people that can do
something well but hate every moment
they're doing it and according to the
film's adaptation he had a lot of fun
doing it and he wasn't mean or harsh or
cynical he was always so upbeat and
optimistic that kind of motivation and
dedication is so impossible not to enjoy
every day and the movie said to him look
like a kid at a candy store I just love
watching his excitement and how happy he
is and no matter how many things
constantly keep getting in his way he
just keeps shrugging saying and I'll
find another way and in the end his work
did find an audience not the audience he
probably intended or for the reasons he
probably intended but the audience is
still there and if we're going by this
film's adaptation my guess is he'd be
proud of it he seems so pleased by the
tiniest things that I bet he wouldn't
enjoy the attention like anything else
in the movie he would just shrug and say
that's show business
make the best of it and that's what this
character always did he made the best of
it yeah some things would get him down
yeah he would hit a bump every once a
while but he always give right back up
and keep going with a smile and a grin
whether a lifetime of fans came of it or
absolutely nothing ever came of it he
would keep doing it regardless and I
think you can make the argument that's
the sign of a true artist that all
artists have to be great but I have
known many that think of themselves as
top but hate what they do the ones
that complain about what they do the
ones they don't appreciate incredible
gift that they have that they can
actually explore this creative realm
when you think about how many aren't
able to do that or aren't able to find
the creative means to do that it would
really does serve as a creative
inspiration
I love how happy he is I love how weird
he is I loved they kept nothing hidden
and I love how he just embraced
everything that came towards him with a
big smile and the thought that if he
just kept moving forward nothing could
stand in his way
well in the end this character got his
wish and serves to be one of my
favorites of all time just as Edie would
never lost the passion for his art I
doubt that I will ever lose the passion
for his
you